[Music]
it was early in july
1881
i was approached by
chum of mine who asked if i'd like a job
as office boy with the western electric
manufacturing company
whose office was on new church street in
the rear
of trinity uh church
i conferred with my parents who thought
well
of the proposition although my
grandparents
had me cut out for a methodist episcopal
domain
i'd have been some minister
in a small long island parish
uh
uh with the uh with the possibility of a
donation party
uh weekly
mr fr wells
manager the new york office of the
western
offered me two dollars a week
i uh stuck out for uh four was finally
employed and at the end
of the uh
first week
received a five dollar gold piece in my
envelope i must have performed uh better
than i thought
uh
my uh
jobs were numerous up to the time i was
elected a director and vice president
in charge of uh purchases and uh
uh traffic and later president and
chairman
of the graybar electric company
uh i retired
uh on the fourth of uh
october last under the uh
old age
pensions pension scheme
i look upon my association with the
telephone pioneers of america with the
utmost
grasp gratification which is something i
would have you all know
uh
and i've had a wonderful time in the
last 50 years but there's still life
in the old man yet
[Music]
you